What lies west of the Sunset Sea? What secrets
does the empire of Yi Ti hold in the east?
Could we hear more about John Snow in the north?
There's no chance these "Game of
Thrones" spin-offs could go south.
In Episode 1 of House of the Dragon, Alicent
Hightower studies the history of Princess Nymeria
with her companion, Princess Rhaenyra Targaryen.
Nymeria is considered such an incredible
character, Arya Stark named her direwolf after
her in the original Game of Thrones series,
and HBO is already developing a
series about her, called 10,000 Ships.
"She took Lord Mors Martell of Dorne to husband,
and burnt her own fleet of Sunspear to show
her own people they were finished running."
The legend of Princess Nymeria begins about a
thousand years prior to the events in Game of
Thrones. Prince Garin thought their people — known
as the Rhoynar — could hold their own against the
dragon-riding Valyrians. Nymeria suspected he was
wrong, and when most of the men died fighting,
or were taken into slavery, she fled Essos with
mostly women and children on the 10,000 ships they
had left. After a few extended stopovers,
Nymeria and the Rhoynar settled in Dorne,
where she burned her enormous but barely
seaworthy fleet to make the point that
they'd found their new home. At the time, the
Dornish were having their own game of thrones,
and Nymeria married her preferred candidate
for the crown, Mors Martell. She became the
Warrior Queen, uniting the kingdom and ushering in
Dorne's culture of independence and gender parity.
It can be argued that a series about Nymeria would
let audiences see one of George R. R. Martin's
greatest heroines in a more nuanced light.
Since she lived so long ago, and what we know
of her borders on myth, 10,000 Ships could
be an ideal vehicle for even more spectacle,
action, and romance than Thrones fans are used to.
For example, besides that unimaginably huge fleet,
the Rhoynar were defeated with an
airborne assault of 300 dragons.
Some storytelling formulas are tried and true,
such as the trope of the reluctant adult forced
to care for the precocious kid. Currently, you
can argue that the biggest guardian-child duo
is the Mandalorian and Grogu, while Game of
Thrones has its own decidedly darker version
with Arya and the Hound. But George R.R.
Martin's novellas — collected as A Knight
of the Seven Kingdoms — happen to contain
an even better one. And it just so happens
that a series based on The Tales of Dunk and
Egg is reportedly a high priority for HBO.
Dunk is Ser Duncan the Tall, a poor squire
from Flea Bottom who pulls himself up by his
own bootstraps and white lies to become a great
knight. Egg is an upper-class boy in disguise
who becomes his squire and traveling companion.
Their adventures are episodic and generally more
light-hearted than the other yarns Martin spins,
but there's still an adequate amount of chivalry,
backstabbing, warmongering, seafaring, and sexual
tension to please the average Thrones viewer.
A Dunk and Egg series would also give
audiences the chance to see characters
in their youth that they've already met. A
Knight of the Seven Kingdoms begins roughly
90 years prior to Game of Thrones and
frequently ties back into existing lore.
For instance, beloved character Ser Brienne
of Tarth is related to Ser Duncan the Tall,
though Martin has not yet revealed
exactly how. But the Season 8 episode
in which she's knighted is not-so-subtly
titled, "A Knight of the Seven Kingdoms."
The most consequential event in George R.R.
Martin's entire body of work could be Aegon
Targaryen's conquest of Westeros. Aegon is such
a pivotal character, the Game of Thrones timeline
revolves around him. Dates are recorded as BC, for
"before conquest" and AC, for "after conquest."
As entertaining as it is to watch his family
line fight each other for the crown 100 years
later in House of the Dragon, or fight
for their very survival centuries later
in Game of Thrones, we'd really like to see
the military campaign that started it all.
Aegon Targaryen the First is probably the most
cinematic personality Martin has yet invented.
This striking, hulking, blonde-haired, purple-eyed
man began his endeavor to unite the Seven Kingdoms
when — as we find out in House of the Dragon —
he had a vision about a threat from the north.
"Aegon foresaw the end of the world of
men. Tis to begin with a terrible winter."
Together with his sister wives, Visenya
and Rhaenys — yes, he married both of his
sisters — and their dragons, Balerion, Meraxes,
and Vhagar, Aegon managed to incorporate six of
Westeros' seven kingdoms into his domain.
Some willingly bent the knee, while others
had to be convinced. Though, ultimately,
he was never able to subdue the Dornish.
Though he looms large in the Game of Thrones
universe, Aegon was a complicated person.
There's enough material just in his tenuous
relationship with the Faith of the Seven
to make for a compelling TV
series — let alone his wives,
his two very different sons, the six Kingdoms
he ruled over, and the many battles which won
him control. Alas, there's no Aegon the
Conqueror show currently in the works.
Arya Stark — played by the perfectly cast Maisie
Williams — was one of the breakout characters of
Game of Thrones and one of the easiest to root
for. When we leave her at the end of Season 8,
she informs her siblings that
she's not going back to Winterfell,
"What's west of Westeros? I don't know."
In Martin's novels, what's west
of Westeros is the Sunset Sea,
a body of water that is believed to be too
vast to cross. So little has been written
about what lies beyond the shores of the
westerlands that the showrunners — or even
Martin himself — could have a blast dreaming up a
new world for Arya and her shipmates to discover.
Exactly what that world would look like — like
Arya's voyage itself — could go in several
different directions. Some characters hold that
there are dangerous creatures, such as krakens or
sea dragons, in the Sunset Sea. If HBO wanted to
lean into magical realism the way it has done with
dragons, White Walkers, the Lord of Light, and the
Faceless Men in Game of Thrones, an Arya-goes-west
series would certainly allow creatives to get
fantastical. An explorer narrative could also
riff on themes related to Europe's colonization
of North and South America, but the main reason
to make an Arya show is simple: more Arya! From
her time as Tywin Lannister's cupbearer to her
world-saving dagger-wielding lunge at the Night
King, Arya was consistently at the center of some
of the series' most iconic scenes. Unfortunately,
as of now, there's no Arya on the horizon.
In House of the Dragon, Corlys Velaryon has
several important posts. He's the husband of
Rhaenys Targaryen, the one-time heir who was
passed over for Viserys' branch of the family
tree. He's the Master of Ships, charged with
outfitting and commanding the royal fleet.
He's also master of the formidable Driftmark
Stronghold, acts as a moderating voice on King
Viserys' small council, and is the richest
man in the world. Corlys will get up to his
fair share of plotting and battling in House
of the Dragon, but decades before that, he
accumulated power and fortune as a young man with
unmatched talent on the high seas and in trade.
Corlys' origin story will either be called
The Sea Snake — a nickname that comes from
the name of a ship he designed and built — or Nine
Voyages, which were the number of journeys he took
to far-off places like Pentos, Volantis, and the
Golden Empire of Yi Ti. Regardless of its title,
it'll illustrate the far-reaching adventures
of this charismatic character before he was a
fixture of King Viserys' court. In the novel Fire
& Blood, Corlys is described as wise in peace,
valiant in war, and someone who clings to life,
"like a drowning sailor clinging
to the wreckage of a sunken ship."
Though Steve Toussaint shines like sunlight
on water as Corlys in House of the Dragon,
a young actor would probably have
to portray him in the spinoff.
While the proposed 10,000 Ships series
focuses on a one-way journey, The Sea
Snake would have a completely different flavor
as an island-hopping, treasure-collecting romp.
One of the places younger Corlys visits
is Yi Ti, a thriving empire in the far
east. The Sea Snake managed to bring back
silks and spices from the Golden Empire,
making him twice as rich as he'd been before.
Jorah Mormont also asks Daenerys to run away
with him to Yi Ti after Khal Drogo's death in Game
of Thrones. But outside of these few connections,
Yi Ti has a rich culture and a dramatic history
all its own — one worthy of its own TV show. HBO
is in pre-production on an animated series that'll
aim to tell the stories of the Golden Empire,
though no release date has been announced and
no other relevant information has been revealed.
While it'd be great to give Asian actors an
opportunity to play live-action roles within the
Game of Thrones universe, the colorful and diverse
world of Yi Ti — which boasts lush farmland,
basilisk-ridden jungles, and bustling
urban centers — can be beautifully
rendered in animation. With a history
that stretches back thousands of years,
occasionally intersecting with Valyria and its
dragons, there's just as much drama between the
various god-emperors who aspire to the Yi
Ti throne as any other royal family in Game
of Thrones. A show that delves into Yi Ti
— a subject which George R. R. Martin has
written comparatively little about — could
make for a refreshing change of scenery.
As Game of Thrones drew to a close, HBO began
mining Martin's novels for more content.
The network reportedly met with potential
writers to develop pitches and assured them
that no concepts were too weird. In total, about
15 spinoff ideas were considered. One of the
pitches that failed to get the greenlight was a
"superhero team-up" story about Westerosi gods.
While that may sound a bit too much like Eternals
— Marvel's foray into ancient religions — a series
that further explores the role of religion
in the Seven Kingdoms could be interesting.
"Does House Tarly keep the Old Gods?"
"No, my Lord. I was named
in the light of the Seven."
Characters in Game of Thrones often
referred to their deities as "the old gods
and the new." The "new" refers to the
Seven — also known as the Seven Gods,
and the Seven-Faced God — who became the deities
of the most widely practiced faith in Westeros.
Followers pray to the Father, the Mother, the
Maiden, the Crone, the Warrior, the Smith, and the
Stranger — each representing a different aspect
of humanity. For example, a soldier might pray to
the Warrior for bravery before an upcoming battle.
This septad may or may not have been real people,
but their origins are from about 6000 years
before the High Sparrow wreaks havoc in Season 5.
As in life, religious factions vie for political
power in Westeros with just as much fervor as
any of the noble families. A show about
the Seven, that flashed back and forth
between the Faith's founding and its influence
circa the original Game of Thrones timeline,
would likely be as dark, mysterious, and
morally ambiguous as the rest of Martin's world.
House of the Dragon is filling in the juicy
backstory of one of Westeros' most notorious
families, and so far, audiences are happy to have
all the salacious details. It stands to reason
they'd be just as curious to know more about the
other family at the center of Game of Thrones,
and HBO may have planned to revisit the
Kingdom of the North with a series called
either Bloodmoon or The Long Night
starring British actress Naomi Watts.
It was to take place in the Age
of Heroes thousands of years ago.
They even spent $30 million on a pilot
before unceremoniously canning the project.
Though legions of Thrones fans would surely love
to see the unaired episode, from context clues,
it sounds like it may have shifted its focus away
from familiar faces and places. Perhaps a series
that sat squarely on the shoulders of King Brandon
Stark — the founder of Winterfell and House
Stark — would've fared better? Part of the fun of
a Bran the Builder story is that the man himself
may never have existed, though there are myriad
carvings depicting his great works, and his body
supposedly lies in Winterfell's crypt. According
to the companion book The World of Ice and Fire,
Bran's legend may be the result of a millennia
of exaggeration and conflation. Generations of
Starks have been named after him, eventually
culminating with King Bran the Broken at the
end of Game of Thrones. We've seen the Seven
Kingdoms in chaos and decline, and now we've
seen them at one of their high points in House of
the Dragon. It'd be fun to see them in the distant
past as one of the franchise's most familiar
locales was in the process of being constructed.
When Game of Thrones ended in 2019, most fans
assumed that they were leaving behind the likes
of Jon Snow and Sansa Stark for good. The
news of spinoffs was already in the air,
and all of them were prequels. That seemed to
make sense, as George R. R. Martin has yet to
complete his novel series, and Thrones stars
like Kit Harington were already moving on to
other projects. So it took a moment for the idea
to register when HBO announced that it intended to
make a true sequel about Jon Snow's life after the
deaths of the Night King and Daenerys Targaryen,
with Harington reprising the role
that made him a household name.
"I don't expect we'll ever see each other again."
"I wouldn't be so sure."
Unlike the rest of the shows in development,
there's no source material upon which to base
a Jon Snow sequel series. All the potential
writers have to go on is that Jon exiled
himself to the North after killing his aunt
and former flame to prevent further atrocities.
We can assume he's been living as a Wildling
again — maybe as their chosen leader — but even
that is an open question. This much of a blank
slate could be a good thing or a bad thing,
but what's promising is that it could
be a chance for viewers to catch up with
their favorite Thrones characters. One could
easily imagine Sansa, Arya, Samwell Tarly,
and even Brienne popping up through cameos
now and then. Even more tantalizing,
it could elevate Kristofer Hivju's
character Tormund Giantsbane to co-star.